[صفق]
مرحبا بكم هناك نحن في المنتصف
Cho Eun-bi 4th dong لطيفة وتصل إلى عام السوق
اللمسة السابقة هي الصمت الألف
قلت لا أستطيع أن أبتهج ، لكنني فعلت
مكتب التفتيش اللجنة المركزية للحزب
عضو اللجنة الدائمة لأبحاث السرطان
نظموا مع هذا الرفيق الهادئ
أنا أخطط لعصابة عمالية في منتصف العام
هذا الرفيق
المشاركون camsa فقرات عنق الرحم هم بنادق تشافي الدولة
متحمس بقلق لبيون بون مونك
قرأت النافذة المنبثقة وكان الأمر على هذا النحو مرة أخرى
آه
هذا هو لدفع مستقبل مشرق
Jebu المفرطة في صراع يستحق العناء
أسماء الشباب بطل التصوير
7 ومعهم تحت اسم مستعار اليقين
التقط صورة تذكارية مع Cheoram
مبني
[صفق]
مجموع الاعتراض مغرفة التضامن يثير للاستمرار
لا اقسم
[موسيقى]
[صفق]